The answer is, it replaces the bottom half with the rotation of the top half.
This question should have been really hard. You have to think about the order
of the numbering of all of the pixels. And imagine everything that happens in
the right order. You haven't seen a problem like this before. If these were all
the pixels of the image. This one would be 0. This would be 1. This would be
picked up pixels minus 1. And this would be picked up pixels minus 2. Now, in
the first iteration of this loop, we would get color c from the ith pixel,
which would be the 0th pixel. Then we would find picked up pixels minus 1 minus
i which in this case would be picked up pixels minus 1. Minus zero, so the last
pixel, and set its color to the color saved in c. So we just copied the color
from here into here. Now, on the next iteration, we'll get the color from one,
right here. Find the pixel at pic.pixels minus 1, minus 1, so right here, and
copy the color into here. It's starting to look like we're just going to rotate
the whole image. But not quite. Imagine that I gets to this second to last
spot. We'll get the color at the second to last spot, and then we'll get the
pixel at the second spot. And we'll copy the color from the second to last spot
back into the second spot. But this is the color the second spot already had.
So the first half of the image won't change. Only the second half of the image
will.